Selena and Demi reunited plus we're
exclusively with Kris Jenner hello
everybody how is it only Tuesday the
struggle bus is alive and well this week
and I don't like well listen I won't
keep it too long because we've got some
goodies for you today
et just sat down with the woman behind
the Kardashian Empire Kris Jenner but
first we got to talk about Selena Gomez
and Demi Lovato reuniting last night the
childhood pals posed together on Monday
night looking super glam at the in Style
Awards in Los Angeles and fans of course
freaked out but can you blame them these
two haven't been seen together in years
and they of course go way back they met
on the set of Barney and Friends and
then co-starred in the 2009 Disney flick
princess protection program
and they've also been cheering each
other on via social media as of late
Demi sent Selena some love and fetish
drop as did Selena when Demi release
sorry not not sorry and most recently
Selena praised Demi for her beautiful
documentary simply complicated telling
her I wish more people were like you now
if you know me you know I love us celeb
feud but I also live for these industry
BFFs and there's not enough of this
mutual love if you ask me
also Selena fans get ready because she's
been teasing an upcoming collab with
marshmallow on Instagram they're single
wolves drops tomorrow morning okay let's
get to Kris Jenner who by the way did
you see her atomic blonde look yesterday
kids this is how you live your truth
hi Lee regal of Queen Kris and I just
imagine bowed out yellow plane in the
background of this you know Chris told
us today was just a wig but listen it's
a look I mean what a time to be alive
folks et's Cameron Mathison caught up
with Chris at the WWD apparel and retail
CEO summit where she spoke today and at
61 chris is grandma to six grandkids
with more on the way Kim and Kanye are
expecting baby number three via
surrogate and our sources tell us Khloe
and Kylie are pregnant too here's what
she had to say about this exciting next
chapter for her daughters beginning with
Kylie how do you think major life
changes for such a young woman will
impact her business world in her
business empire i think she is a very
strong
and I think that the strength that she
has as a woman and an entrepreneur and a
business person and everything that
she's got going on she's really I think
equipped to handle whatever comes her
way I'm so proud of that kid she's a
good good girl with a big heart
Chloe's Jean line is going very very
well good America she's good she's and
she's in love she's in a great place as
a mom yeah you guys over the moon yeah I
am so over the moon we love Tristan so
much and she's so happy and she's been
through so much and I think that just
seeing her be able to do something so
creative with good American on top of it
to have and be in such a great place in
her personal life is amazing yeah she's
she's really happy Kim has announced
that she's expecting kimchi and Kanye
are expecting baby number three and how
would you joy you get from from being a
grandma from being a lovey lovey lovey I
mean everybody don't want jobs that's
like yeah that's my best one right
that's my favorite yeah it's the best
you know they there's the kids bring
such joy you know and it makes
everything worth it of course her family
is everything to her and Chris's help
create an empire that is now reaching
billion-dollar status you heard that
right
so I guess you really can't have it all
folks and I bow down to you Chris are
you guys be sure to check out et tonight
where cam gets Chris to prank call Chloe
and it is so good more of that tonight
all right speaking of pranks
Sam Smith got the scare of his life on
Ellen today not once but twice how's
this for a shocker the two good acted by
singer confirmed he is off the market
presumably with 13 reasons why start
Brandon Flynn clean with snaps mooching
on in New York City last month in fact
Sam told Ellen he spent his time off
after winning the Oscar kissing what he
joke was hundreds of them you're not
single right now anymore right no no
good good for you crazy when I pull yeah
you found somebody yeah when well it's
weird bringing out an album and not
being single because we're bright in the
lonely hour was so lonely but now I'm
singing songs about this another guy but
I'm quite happy so it's probably weird
and I don't even know what a happy
record from Sam Smith sounds like but I
cannot wait the Grammy winner noted that
he sings about that mystery ex in four
or five songs on the new album but the
rest of the tunes are about other men in
his life are you guys can we get a like
or a comment for all these celebs just
living their truth I'm still here for it
and thank you guys as always for
watching
hit subscribe to our channel because we
are almost at 800,000 subscribers and
have something special planned for you
guys so stay tuned I'll see you tomorrow